ON DEMOCRATS THERE WILL BE
RECKONING AND ACCOUNTING OF EACH
MEMBER OF THIS YEAR.
WE ARE GOING TO WIN.
IN NOVEMBER.
THAT'S LOT OF BRAVDO.
THE NEW POLL OF HOUSE DISTRICTS
FOUND REPUBLICAN HOLD 4-POINT
ADVANTAGE THAT'S 46-42%.
AND THAT'S MASSIVE ADVANTAGE FOR
THE GOP.
PRESIDENTIAL APPROVAL IS IN THAT
GAP AS MUCH AS 37% APPROVE OF
BIDEN IN THOSE BATTLE GROUNDS.
60% APPROVE OF TRUMP.
WHAT'S MORE THIS LATEST POLICY
DEMOCRATICS ARE LOSING GROUNDS
WITH NON WHITE VOTERS ESPECIALLY
HISPANIC AND ASIAN.
NOW THE ONE RED FLAG FOR G.O.P.
ACCORDING TO THIS SENATE RACES
WERE POTENTIALLY WEAKER ACCOUNTS
ALLOW INDIVIDUAL DEMOCRAT
CANDIDATES TO RUN AHEAD OF WHERE
BIDEN IS.
HERE IS RICK SCOTT FLORIDA
SENATOR AND CHAIRMAN OF
REPUBLICAN COMMITTEE THIS FOURTH
DAY YOUR HOME STATE WHERE ARE
RIGHT NOW WITH US SENATOR.
THANK YOU.
SENATE WHAT LOT OF REPUBLICANS
ARE WORRIED ABOUT.
LET'S START IN PENNSYLVANIA.
WE HAVE JOHN FEATHERMAN WHO HAS
BEEN M A.
AND MI AAGAIN DOCTOR OZ VERY
WELL-KNOWN WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN THERE?
>> OZ IS GOING TO WIN.
IF ALL THIS TIED TO MONEY.
WE GOT RAISE MONEY BUT DR. OZ
NOT ONLY A GOOD DAY GUY HE CASE
OF ABOUT THIS STATE.
HE WORKING HARD.
EVERY TIME I TALK TO HIM HE IS
CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
PUTTERMAN NO WHERE TO SEEN.
>> HE HAS $9 MILLION.
I THINK OZ HAS 1.5.
WHERE ARE THE REPUBLICAN?
WE GOT TO RAISE THE MONEY.
DEMOCRAT ALWAYS HAVE MORE MONEY
IF YOU WANT TO HELP US YOU CAN
HELP US.
YOU CAN HIM GET MONEY BUT HE
GOING TO RUN GOOD RACE.
HE HARD WORKER.
HE IS A DOCTOR HE CARES ABOUT
PEOPLE.
>> WE GOT TO GET MONEY.
ISN'T BEST ARGUMENTS RACES EVEN
GETTING AWAY INTEREST INDIVIDUAL
VOTE FOR DEMOCRAT IS A VOTE FOR
HIGH GAS PRICES.
>> GAS PRICE.
FOOD PRICE.
AFGHANISTAN BEGAN WITHDRAWAL.
OPEN BORDER.
BIDEN NUMBERS ARE HORRIBLE
BECAUSE BIDEN POLICIES ARE BAD
AND DEMOCRATS.
THEY ARE VOTING HORRIBLY.
>> YES VOTE FOR DEMOCRAT FOR
CHUCK SCHAUMBURG YOU ARE AS
MAJORITY LEADER.
REPUBLICAN ENERGIZED EVEN
PENNSYLVANIA SINCE 1998 THIS IS
THE FIRST TIME REPUBLICAN VOTED
THAN DEMOCRAT.
THAT TELLS USSOUS TWICE MANY
REPUBLICAN THAN DEMOCRAT IN
OHIO.
125,000 MORE ANTI-DEPRESSANT
SO, WE I MEAN WE GET MONEY WE
WIN.
>> WELL YOU GOT OPEN THEIR
WALLETS HERE.
.
ISN'T ECONOMY OR INFLATION THAT
WILL MATTER TO VOTERS.
WATCH MS NBC.
IN ARE FOLKS THAT YOU KNOW WOULD
CONSIDER THEMSELVES TO BE
CONSERVATIVE TO BE PRO LIFE.
AND YET AT THE SAME TIME THEY
HAVE A TIME STOMACHING WHAT THEY
SAW UNFOLD ON JANUARY 6TH.
AND THE EFFORTS YUNGDZ MINE THE
DEMOCRACY HAVE COME AFTER THIS.
I KNOW THESE ARE REAL
CONVERSATIONS THAT ARE PLAYING
OUT IN HOUSEHOLDS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND WHY SO PEOPLE MANY
PEOPLE HAVE DETERMINING WHETHER
THEY ARE REPUBLICAN.
>> OKAY.
SENATOR, AROUNDED DINNER TABLE?
ARE PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT LIZ
CHENEY AND BENNY THOMPSON.
>> GAS PRICES.
FOOD PRICES.
OPEN BORDER.
YOU KNOW THIS BIDEN HOW WEAK
BIDEN IS THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
NUMBER ONE FAMILY ISSUES WHY ARE
THEY TEACHING CRT.
WHY ARE THEY DEFUNDING THE
POLICE.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS I LOVED
ABOUT YOUR BLUE PRINTSDZ THAT
YOU LAID OUT.
IT WAS VERY SPECIFIC.
ISSUE AFTER ISSUE.
CONCERN THAT A LOT OF US WHEN
REPUBLICAN TAKE POWER, IF LIKE
30 DAYS WELL WHAT DO WE DO NO.
DEMOCRATS ARE READY FOR DAY ONE.
ARE YOU GUYS READY ON DAY ONE
OVERSIGHT.
INVESTIGATIONS, LEGISLATION?
>> WELL I AM GOING TO DO
EVERYTHING I CAN.
WE GOT TO GET READY.
I PUT A PLAN.
RESCUE AMERICA.
WE GOT HAVE TO IS PLAN.
WE GOT TEACH OUR KIDS VERY
GREATEST COUNTY.
WE STOP RACIAL POLITICS.
WE GOT TO MAKE SURE WE ARE GOING
TO SECURE BORDER AND CUT TACKS.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE HAVE TO
DO WE HAVE TO FIGHT FOR THOUGH
THINGS.
NEWT DID IN 94.
THEY WENT IN THERE THAT'S WHAT
WE HAVE DO YOU KNOW